[Music]
new revelations in the russia
investigation documents show that a
member of
special counsel robert mueller's team
thought that the russia collusion probe
was a quote dead end and that the
prosecution of michael flynn was part of
an attitude to get
trump and attorney general bill barr
revealing that a primary
source of the steele dossier was
investigated for suspected ties to
russia
president trump weighed in on this
earlier you see the stuff that just came
out on russia
so we caught him called max we caught
him called it was a whole
conspiracy and it was the worst thing
anyone's ever seen
and it was a take down they were the
ones conspired
they got caught let's see what happens
let's see what happens we went through
three years of of crap
crap indeed um dana
do you think that there is room with
less than 40 days out for the election
to make the quote
russia hoax a plot line again um
for voters going to the polls on
november 3rd and before or is this just
what trump loves to talk about well i
think that one i think you should talk
about it because there's new information
um i sort of want i want to see the
entire report right because i feel like
when things are dripped out like this
that like next week and jesse says there
will be more documents on monday we'll
have more
maybe then by the time it comes out
there's yet another one that just
disavows that part so
i when it drips and drabs i don't love
it but i i do think that
it's pretty serious stuff and it needs
to be
i'm glad that they're investigating it
um will it affect the election i feel
like those decisions those
voters are already baked in so i don't
know how much of a difference it will
make in
actual votes yeah because we are seeing
in this election versus 2016 that there
are basically no undecideds left right
it's about 90 to 92 percent of americans
know what they're doing
um so i'm going to turn it to you jesse
we've talked about well i'm undecided
i'm waiting for the debates
yeah let's see how those shows you want
to see how chris wallace does yeah and
uh
see who impresses you here's here's what
i saw this is what we found out
because what they did was they they
unredacted the little footnote in the ig
report
so it turns out hillary clinton paid for
for an interference in an election from
russia because the primary source for
the steele dossier
was a suspected russian spy how do we
know that
the fbi investigated the guy for three
years for being a suspected russian spy
so then the fbi knows he's a suspected
russian spy
they hide it from the court they hide
from the court that hillary paid for the
dossier and then they doctored evidence
to get the warrant
that's kind of a big deal then all those
other
uh interviews from the fbi agent who was
on the mueller team and some of the text
messages
show there was no evidence of collusion
the entire time
and that the mueller team was out to get
trump from the beginning
and that general flynn they had nothing
on flynn they even looked into his
finances without a warrant
using national security letters they had
nothing on flynn
and some of the fbi agents were actually
so nervous they took out an insurance
policy because they thought the thing
was going to get turned around into a
criminal investigation
against them because they were breaking
so many laws
and they were joking about destroying
their iphones
that's pretty funny and all this time
the media
has been reporting the russia
disinformation
how stupid are they so my favorite thing
about doing this show
is that i don't even have to ask you a
question and you're just gonna tell
everybody
what you think about it uh greg i see
you nodding and you did
hear hillary clinton your favorite name
should be mentioned so part of
in these new documents it's revealed
that durham is going to be looking at
the clinton foundation again
an entity that has been investigated uh
more than anything else that i can think
of
um where do you think something like
that goes and
do you think that voters have moved on
from talking about the clintons i
understand she's on tv and i know that
that annoys you
but people are looking i know what i
know because you told me in the ability
oh i said i love it
well okay what i like
is that now you a democrat are concerned
that viewers are getting tired of this
story four years you were pushing it
down our throats and now it's like
oh this jesse this russian business
isn't it time to move on oh dana is
do we really need to talk about this you
guys have been making us talk about it
every day so sorry now you're gonna eat
the breakfast that we've been
eating by the way jessica just for today
can i call you juan
just for now so juan how does it feel
to be pushing this uh uh obstruction and
collusion
uh uh accusation only to find out that
it's your side that had been doing it
all along
you were bo you're it was your group
behind the russian collusion
not the republicans and not trump that's
got to eat you
up inside juan i know wang can't hear me
so i'm going to go even further
we now have concrete evidence of a coup
attempt right this is a coup
attempt and we were all supposed to say
don't say
coo don't say ku that's crossing the
line
well now we can say coup marilyn mccoo
and billy davis jr
all right the big question is why one
will the media do two things take a
moment of self reflection
no no no no how about backing up the car
in reversing direction and paying amends
by investigating this new story
which is what a fair and balanced
journalists would do
no they aren't even covering it yeah
okay so
juan would go you're now just greg
you're now
[Laughter]
what a load of crap yeah i mean if you
want to talk
you have to say i can't believe this
table
i wish there was a table but i i
actually really can't believe this table
and if you want to talk about new
evidence coming out let's talk about
andrew weissman's book where he says
yeah the trustworthy weissman yeah who
is
one of the most corrupt prosecutors in
the entire country
look can we get the 32 million dollars
that was spent on the special counsel
investigation
back to the taxpayers yeah the fact that
this happened
even though they knew there was nothing
there and the trust that was broken
between the american people and things
like i don't know the federal bureau of
investigation
which is supposed to protect people and
not be used as a political weapon
against political opponents that you
don't like and people are wondering well
you asked the question does this affect
voters well if joe biden is going to try
and portray himself as someone who
has a deep 40-year washington record
he was part of the obama administration
which carried this out there was a
meeting in the oval office on january
5th
about these things so yes it has to do
with government corruption
and president trump still portraying
himself as an outsider who isn't
involved in all of the corruption of dc
which has turned into
government being weaponized against
conservatives and political opponents
under the obama administration which
happened multiple times in a number of
ways
we are out of time so i can't go point
by point but if you're concerned about
taxpayer dollars president trump can
take the weekend off golfing
that'll save you millions and then you
can have your mueller money
in the country
well i'm in charge actually yeah but i
want to do that the fastest up next